Анатолій, дуже приємно!
Багато чув про вас.
Це Ігор Ященко, засновник «Дентал ТриЗуб».
Можете матюкнутись, можете когось
покритикувати — це так, як варіант.
Все, що вважаєте за потрібне,
тільки щоб це не був нудний ефір.
Скільки буде часу?
40 хвилин, можливо, 45.
Будемо бачити, як у нас взагалі розмова йтиме.
Ви — офіційний представник Міністерства
закордонних справ Естонії чи просто культури?
Я роблю культурні проєкти.
Культурно-гуманітарні?
Так, за підтримки Міністерства
іноземних справ Естонії.
Все, зрозуміло.
Пане Анатоліє,
а де ви цих чугунків понабирали?
З України.
Попривозили?
Можна сидіти.
В ім'я Отця, і Сина, і Святого Духа.
Амінь.
Отче наш, що єси на небесах!
Нехай святиться ім'я Твоє,
нехай прийде Царство Твоє,
нехай буде воля Твоя,
як на небі, так і на землі.
За вчорашній день троє поранених.
Як ми були з Богданом останній раз в
Авдіївці, снайпери двох застрелили.
Снайпери не дають жити.
Можна ще сховатися від важкої артилерії,
а від снайпера дуже важко сховатися
і дуже важко з ними боротися.
Шановні друзі, ми в ефірі.
Один, два, три.
Точно в ефірі.
Шановні українці, нагадую:
у нас у програмі Анатолій Лютюк,
керівник Центру української
культури в Таллінні,
організації, яка разом
з Міністертвом закордонних справ Естонії
надає допомогу нашим переселенцям,
пораненим хлопцям і тим, хто цього потребує,
хто проживає на лінії розмежування вогню.
Тобто, ви приїжджаєте з Естонії,
шукаєте тут контакти
для того, щоб продуктивно допомогти там,
де це найбільш потрібно?
Саме так.
Тобто не вас в Естонії шукають за
допомогою, а ви шукаєте такі можливості?
Це взагалі вищий пілотаж.
До речі, не тільки по лінії фронту.
У Франківську є фонд «Чисте серце»,
і вони ще додають свої гроші,
продукти і оплачують транспорт.
Так, прошу.
Є така подруга,14-річна дівчина,
онука моєї коліжанки,
яка почула, що я їду на фронт, і каже:
«Анатолій, я хочу з тобою поїхати».
Я кажу: «Та нема питань!
Мама пустить — чом би й ні».
І вона через пару днів приходить:
«Анатолій, давай свої документи.
Мама завтра йде до нотаріуса» —
бо вона дитина, 14 років.
Я у шоці був.
Тобто, 14-річна естонка знає про війну в Україні
і сама збирає допомогу для України.
Так, ціла школа збирає,
але Анна Брітвина поїхала.
20-го серпня і 24-го серпня 1991-го року
Естонія і Україна проголосили свою Незалежність.
І щороку ми відзначаємо ці свята, тому що
це — головні свята для кожної країни.
Шановне товариство, з вашого дозволу
я хочу показати один плакат,
який ми з дяком тримали
в пам'ятному 1988-му році.
Це буде найкоротша промова.
Всі ці документи ми передамо в Музей окупації,
тільки я не знаю коли
— коли пані Віра скаже, тоді й передамо.
Дякую.
Треба поставити.
А то вже буде не оригінал.
Десь хоч малесенькими буквами.
Ми всі знаємо, що, на жаль,
четвертий рік поспіль
ми починаємо наші свята,
які мають бути радісними,
з хвилини мовчання.
Я спочатку думав, коли їхав на фронт:
«Я зараз розберусь з тим, що там робиться».
І коли я зрозумів, що взагалі нічого
не знаю, ні в чому не розбираюся,
я вирішив, що я буду допомагати
тільки там, де я знаю,
не робити жодних політичних висновків
і збиратиму історії про доброту,
але вони мають відношення до природи.
Я ще роблю іграшки.
Вивчаю народні іграшки.
Іграшки різних народів — у кожній країні
у мене є консультанти по іграшках.
Я зробив того коня, який поїхав на Донбас.
Основа яка? Всі кажуть:
погано, погано, все погано, кінець.
І тоді я себе привчив
кожен день шукати щось добре.
Я живу життям своєрідним і кожен день
я щось добре маю знайти.
Я почав збирати історії про звірів в АТО.
Це така цікава тема.
Поїхав я в Авдіївку, в Промзону,
і дивлюсь — птаха сидить.
Ясно, дід рота відкрив: «Що це за птаха
і чому я її не знаю?».
Підійшов до птахи, вона перелітає,
я повернувся назад,
і потім мені воїни сказали:
«Ееей!» — там розтяжка була.
Перший раз у житті я побачив ту розтяжку
і до мене дойшло,
що ще крок — і дід полетів би.
Мати Божа Триручиця,
Ти взяла під Свою опіку землю Естонії.
Небо, море, озера та ріки
мають синій колір твоїх очей.
Допоможи нам зберегти в мирі
наше небо, море, озера та ріки.
Наша чорна земля
має колір Твоїх страждань.
Ми також готові страждати,
щоб захистити нашу Землю.
Білий сніг та лілії Твоїх озер
нагадують нам про Твою чистоту.
Дай і нам чистоти і Божого світла
для щоденної молитви
за збереження життя навколо нас.
Допоможи нам в цьому, Діво Маріє!
В ім'я Отця, Сина та Святого Духа.
Амінь.
Йо-майо! От профі!
Це тєма!
Мистецтво!
Оце профі!
Рукошльопки!
Так робиться історія!
Забув вам сказати:
оце не відмивається днів вісім.
Якщо врахувати, що я професійний художник,
то розкажи комусь другому.